Denmark Danish cake our friends Millie
and Lynette are visiting us from Denmark
I've never been to Dane Lynn I hear it's
very nice
I've never eaten Danish food I don't
even know what to expect this fish maybe
I really have no idea
I know Legoland is there so I'm hoping
that the foods can like connect in cool
ways Millie is the food like Legos no
have you ever tried uh would you look at
that it's like a poppy seed it's gone I
like any food that I can spy through do
you think they need this many poppy
seeds to make it taste like poppy seeds
what is this called
tape look what it's table mmm tapeworms
mmm it's like a croissant yeah but it's
so sweet in the mill it makes a great
sound - mmm it's like it's raining
outside bring on the next dish oh do
they still call them danishes well we
call them cake oh this isn't a cake it's
Danish our cakes and pastries really
popular in Denmark yeah especially for
breakfast and how are you guys so skinny
hmm
so this is a cake oh you're encoded Rina
would be Noble
let's find it's like a little raspberry
nipple no I don't like it that much
what Isis well I ate for breakfast I eat
think I don't know eggs this aching this
Limi
cannot read them do you want an answer
the question dogs are here a hot dog
yeah with purple on it
we got red cabbage and fried onions so
vinegary huh yeah that's the smelliest
wiener I've ever encountered
all right any any words of advice and
just put it anywhere you guys have seen
lady the [ __ ]
I think we should ladyandtramp it no
mmm what a fun way to you know do people
in Dane Lin laughs at Wiener jokes
Denmark Denmark it's really good it's a
really solid dog I really like how
oniony everything is also onions most
overrated vegetable of all time
overrated all right I mean I have seen
which is little tiny toasts what's up
with this bread it looks like banana
bread lot of seeds in Danish it's called
import and it's very healthy so this is
like the national bread of Denmark yeah
Denmark's favorite bread what a joy to
have a bread for your country is it a
secret to that great Danish skin oh yes
this is pear gotta cheese salmon there's
egg and shrimp and huh little labogen I
still have sausage bread I like watching
you eat like watching a baby
mmm oh good yeah good apartment isn't my
perfect meal I think the bread is really
unique I've never had shrimp on my bread
before Kevin no I haven't Oh
I'm the crazy person oh that was a
little upside down half Oh what is that
there's like yellow stuff orange stuff
green stuff what is this it looks like
yogurt with bacon in it it's come to
look what little blue would it look like
chimichurri sauce oh then it starts
scooping it there's more underneath and
yeah supposed to look like me you know
in sci-fi movies where a scientist tries
to make some sort of new animal and then
it comes out like this professor come
quick we've made a new rule of law what
is this made of it
it's made of a beer and bread beer yeah
your country is amazing let's eat this
delicious multicolored food
that is shocking it is a copy cake it's
like liquid coffee cake that's really
good interesting it's sweet what is
going on blah more like cool oh wow the
entire food pyramid in one you got grain
you got fruit you got vegetables you got
beer so final thoughts I'm actually
surprised that we don't have more Danish
food saturating restaurants worldwide
like you'd think if Legos could take
over the holy goddamn world why didn't
the food join with it obsessed with
Legos yeah cuz Legos are awesome yes
good I Denmark and Damon is Denmark I'm
not sure if this is offensive or
adorable a little bit of folks well then
we nailed it